center center kann es mich hören hallo
mein name ist luca und herzlich
willkommen zu einer weiteren folge face
railways trick ist ein programm wo ich
quasi einfach auf einen charakter a
zur kollision beider
ich habe davon schon mal ein video
hochgeladen das verlinkt ich euch hier
das ist allerdings schon sauer alt und
das war nicht so geschnitten wie ich es
jetzt mache ich mache jetzt aber noch
nicht besser oder der standardmäßige
charakter hierbei ist der was machst du
mit deinem komischen auge der you can
stay together mir egal das hier ist der
standardmäßige charakter das ist dieser
komische fuchs hier und egal wo ich hin
das mache ich aber nicht gerade mit
meinen augen egal wo ich hingucke der
guckt dahin und egal wie sprecher ist
halt alles ein bisschen verzögert aber
das ist blöd weil wenn ich mich jetzt zu
kämmen dreher dreht er sich auch weg wir
können hier oben links auf avatar ist
klicken und wir sehen schon oh mein gott
sind das viele charaktere mittlerweile
ihr wisst ja dass ich sehr gerne burger
erster deswegen habe ich mir gedacht ich
werde einen burger
halter dass herr megageil die land gar
nicht was für ein bock ich habe jetzt
das ganze ist immer noch keine
ausgereifte version also sind gerade
versionen 1 260 1.26 bild bild 37
arbeitsmittel schon mal so weit dass ein
paar mehr charaktere haben als beim
letzten video was ihr euch am anfang
verlinkt habe ach was wenn man dann
nicht lieber als ein tiger im mantel in
der großstadt
na hat sie heute abend schon was vorher
sexy lady
ich kann
was ist wenn ich schiele der sieht man
das
sieht man das wenn ich schiele zu
unglaublich weh wir haben übrigens heute
gesagt dass ich gestern im video mit
super idee die avantgarde den kalender
aufzumachen deswegen mache ich heute
einfach zwei türen auf hintertürchen 19
befand sich so einen tisch spiegel und
hintertürchen 20 war ein abschnitt
schwammig gleich das einfach wieder hin
und wir machen weiter wo new face die
taktik ist hier noch einer mit dem raum
so sehen ca gerade 90 des videos aus
was haben wir denn sonst noch so alles
für avatare wow ich bin ein geschenk und
in mir ist eine wahre pop
was das was mache ich hier ich finds
halt blöd dass es noch nicht perfekt
klappt von diesem augen zu augen
aufmachen mäßig
und wie knuffig ich bin ein kleiner wolf
oder per das pärchen hat aber nicht
anders verdient hat diese ballon
hintergründe
meine damen und herren herzlich
willkommen hier zur 20 uhr tagesschau
unsere heutigen themen sind es wurde ein
tier gesichtet
der hatte eine tea party mütze auf und
braune augen und empfiehlt suchen die
mit der polizei dazu haben wir mit einem
augenzeugen gesprochen
biedermann ich habe überhaupt keine
ahnung wovon er redet ich war das nicht
ich habe zwar auch die mütze auf und ich
habe auch braune augen aber ich kann nur
wieder zurückgeben mich war das wirklich
nicht mann
wirklich wenn wir wieder live
ok alles klar und der kombi damit auch
schon direkt zum wetter meine damen und
herren wo wir unseren außen
korrespondenten direkt vor ort haben
center
und da kann es mich hören irgendwie ja
man die hammer die habe ich übel zwecke
knallt heute wird es nie eine verbindung
zum center aufbauen
rudolf was wir sind und ihre sendung ne
quatsch verlagern wie scheiße ich meinen
job eigentlich finde habe ich da noch
die currywurst lest ihr hier in einem
barren kleben
das weiß auf jeden fall mit 20 uhr
tagesschau mit geschaltet doch morgen
wieder ein
und damit war es das auch jetzt schon
von meiner seite hier vom video ich
hoffe euch hat es gefallen
wenn ja dann zeigt man mit einer
bewertung ich habe halt am ende ein
bisschen versucht das ganze ein bisschen
role play mäßig zu machen so eine kleine
news show zu parodieren vielleicht hat
solcher gefallen und wir wollten noch
ein teil von facebook dann schreibt man
das gerne mal die kommentare in welche
ideen für den zweiten teil bei mir macht
ultra viel spaß und ich hab die apps
heute wieder entdeckt und dann sehen wir
uns morgen am 21
ciao